have any of your friends ever told you
that they think I'm good-looking
no true I guess I just want her to be
honest and I just want us to laugh
ultimately just embarrass the [ __ ] out
of each other
Jennifer is the biggest liar in the
family easily and you know and when I
say the family I mean I don't just mean
the nuclear family I mean the entire
extended family I think she tells all
kinds of unnecessary white lies I would
strongly more and caution here because
whatever you say to me to try and
embarrass me I will make it 10 times
worse for you
do you think you're funnier than me no
100% no true oh my god honey mom here
welcome that's so nice of him
have you ever spit in my food yes true
Wendy sure I've done it multiple times
have you ever had a threesome no true
it's kind of hoping you ha does your
boyfriend think I'm cool
yes that's a lie uncle who do you think
is better looking you or me
you yeah true why are you so
disappointed like you can find I wanted
to find I'm a nice person
do you think I'm a good person yes true
Oh finally my god I might have saved you
from a lot of [ __ ] do you get jealous
when I'm successful no true cool have
you ever been attracted to any of my
ex-boyfriends no that's a lie
have you ever been in love no that's a
lie who is it I mean I love my dogs and
I love my parents
do you enjoy living with me yes
it's a lie if you're not an honest
person like them there is no trust and
there's no foundation there so that
sucks for the most part I think everyone
should be honest or else it's gonna come
in bite you in the ass so the fact that
the things that she lied about work I
feel like they were minimal they were
more like hilarious but I love that we
still have a strong honest foundation